Well,
it's,
that's another thing about having the limited amount of weight classes when you
jump up your chances.
Crazy man.
He's like one 74 one 75 on fight day.
Yeah.
If I can guys one 90 yeah.
But with a lot of energy.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
Is it his age?
I think it's probably good meals.
Yeah.
I think it's probably a good move though at his age.
You know,
I think he's back from UFC ultimate fighter one inside.
We knew though,
like on the show that he was the one they would go forever.
We'd be with a house that I know he's just crazy.
Tuesday ASM still very gotta stop.
I mean when w when he beat Micky Gall that way I was,
I was incredibly impressed when I'm like,
this kid might test him.
He didn't test him at all.
I mean it was amazing.
So Prime Diego Sanchez performance 15 years into the game.
I mean just even,
not even just into,
that's just into the UFC.
He had an amateur fights and our professional fights,
rather before the UFC,
he spent in the UFC for 15 years,
or at least 14.
Right?
2004.
2005 was season one.
We shot it 2004.
2005 so yeah.
What's up?
Get somewhere somewhere in the neighborhood of 15 years.
Just amazing that he's so enthusiastic about it still.
Yeah.
They'll give them a vase for his top of his mantle piece on it.
But this fire or something,
carriage clock or something just to recognize the 15 years.
Yeah.
That's,
um,
that's a long time in a combat sport.
Long time.
So that's the other thing,
man,
that is not the norm.
That's a deviation,
right.
Either you got it for,
I made it nine years in the UFC,
eight years actually.
And you know,
I didn't have that many fights.
I broke down.
I fall apart.
It's pretty average,
you know,
I was like,
Whoa,
is me?
And then when you look at the data,
it's like,
oh no,
I'm,
I'm just average 35.
That's when you start fall apart when you.